i'm here you can't doubt her
determination to carry on the queen back
at work at windsor how are you
well as you can see i can't move as
scandals linked her children keep coming
now the metropolitan police
investigating cash for honors claims
around prince charles's charity
the allegations first came out last
summer that michael fawcett one of his
longest-serving aides and the chief
executive of the prince's foundation
may have offered to help a saudi
businessman to secure an honor and
british citizenship in return for a
donation the palace says prince charles
had no knowledge of the alleged offers
and the met says there's been no arrests
or interviews under caution
the fact that he made a statement today
rather than simply investigating behind
the scenes demonstrates that they put it
in the public domain they're taking the
matter seriously and in my view they
need to pursue it without fear or favor
the timing could not be any worse as the
fallout from prince andrew settling his
sex abuse case continues and demands for
him to be stripped of further titles
including councillor of state and even
duke of york
people in my city 88 of them have said
that they want that shootdown to be
removed and investigating this this
isn't a simple matter where the queen
could remove certain titles from her son
she couldn't remove the title of duke
that has to be through a parliamentary
process
in york there was the sense that
negative headlines are overshadowing the
queen's platinum jubilee year
the queen bless her and she does a
fantastic job for the for the country
and i believe she's been deeply deeply
hurt and embarrassed by this episode it
sounds a bit messy at the moment but uh
i think there's still a place for them i
do feel sorry for the queen
because she above everyone has given
everything
whether it's about how prince andrew
will pay his settlement or how prince
charles's charity is run it does all
raise questions about the transparency
of the institution
i don't see any advantage
for us to treat the royal family as if
they were politicians and demand total
transparency i think the real problem is
when they cross the line and the
consequences for errors are catastrophic
in a year that is all about showcasing
the monarchy there will be a sense of
relief that a trial isn't hanging over
them but also a realization they aren't
clear yet when it comes to the
repercussions of ongoing investigations
rhiannon mills sky news